واحة دبي للسيليكون هي القلب النابض
للمشهد التكنولوجي في المدينة، وبالنسبة لبعض
المقيمين مثل أنيت التي انتقلت إلى هنا منذ 8
سنوات قادمة من المملكة المتحدة،
قد تبدو النزهة السريعة هنا وكأنها رحلة عبر الزمن
ومغامرة نحو المستقبل.
الروبوت وكل
ذلك سهل على التطبيق ويأتي
مباشرة إلى باب منزلك، من الجيد
رؤيتهم في جميع أنحاء المجتمع، ومن
الممتع أن جميع الأطفال يحبونهم، ومن
الممتع رؤية هذه
الروبوتات الآلية وهي تقدم وجبات جاهزة إلى حوالي
300 منزل  في حي آنيت في غضون
15 دقيقة تقريبًا بينما لا يمكنهم
السفر سوى حوالي 5 كيلومترات من
مركز التسوق المحلي هذا، تساعدهم أجهزة الاستشعار والخوارزميات التي تم إنشاؤها
باستخدامها على التحرك
بأمان لتجنب العوائق أثناء مشاركة
الطريق وبرنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يمنع
التعرف على الوجه يحمي
العميل.  الهوية عندما يصل الطعام
إلى عتبة بابهم، كل ذلك جزء من
مشروع تجريبي واحد بقيادة
شركة توصيل الطعام "طلبات" ومقرها دبي، حيث
يركزون على الابتكار والاستدامة.
ما ندركه بعد
الوباء، كنا بحاجة إلى أن نكون أكثر كفاءة
مع أسطولنا، كان هناك فرز
الركاب في ظروف معينة
تتمتع الروبوتات بنفس القيمة المضافة التي يتمتع بها الراكب
لمسافات أقصر، وقد يكون طلب الطعام عبر
تطبيقات التوصيل سريعًا وسهلاً،
ولكن الراحة يمكن أن تأتي
بتكلفة بيئية اعتمادًا على
وضع النقل الذي وجده الباحثون في المملكة المتحدة
في المدن المزدحمة.  مثل
توصيل الطلبات في لندن بواسطة السيارات أو
الدراجات النارية يمكن أن يكون أكثر تلويثًا بنسبة 5 إلى 11 مرة
من توصيل الطلبات بالدراجات،
يمكن أن تساعد الروبوتات مثل هذه في الحد من
تلك الانبعاثات لأنه بدلاً من
استخدام البنزين، يتم تشغيلها بواسطة
بطاريات كهربائية قابلة لإعادة الشحن، ونحن نحاول
تقليل البصمة الكربونية لدينا.  نعلم أن
هذا إجراء صغير ولكننا كنا
نتطلع دائمًا إلى تطوير
تقنيات جديدة أفضل
للبيئة على مستوى العالم، تبلغ قيمة أعمال توصيل الأغذية
أكثر من 150 مليار دولار، وقد تضاعف حجمها أكثر من ثلاثة أضعاف
خلال السنوات الست الماضية، وهذا
النمو يجعل التشغيل المستدام
أولوية قصوى بالنسبة لنا  "أمامنا طريق طويل لنقطعه فيما يتعلق
بالوفاء بالتزام تكنولوجيا Net Zero،
ستكون جزءًا كبيرًا من
الوصول إلى ذلك، أعتقد أن هناك
فوائد هائلة في الابتعاد عن
الأشكال التقليدية للتوصيل إلى استخدام
الروبوتات واستخدام السيارات الكهربائية
المحتملة  طائرات بدون طيار، لذا فإن الاستثمار المبكر في
التكنولوجيا يؤتي ثماره بشكل عام، وأعتقد أن
دبي مثال جيد على ذلك، ولكن
في حين أن طائرات Talbots لا يمكنها
السفر إلا لمسافات قصيرة في الوقت الحالي، يبدو أنها
تستعد للتو للوصول إلى
خط النهاية نحو
الهدف النهائي  لتصبح
[موسيقى]
أكثر اخضرارًا